ce soit on a la chance je voulais dit de
recevoir enrico macias donc les
chroniqueurs ont envie de rendre hommage
à tout ce qui est orientale donc ils se
sont tous mis dans la peau de chanteurs
orientaux on va commencer avec le plus
grand bien sûr un deuxième rico macias
est avec nous applaudissements polis
[Musique]
koné
[Applaudissements]
voir
mon coeur me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vous plaît pas donc tu sors et ma
danseuse du rendez vous en faites et
vous vous aider il est prêté à khémisset
qui puisse me ça c'est ma danseuse ça
m'a coûté cher d alors et vous voulez
vous je vous le jure c'est une horreur
je sais ça faisait bien démarré mais
vous êtes une catastrophe a wing se
ressemblent pas tenter de leur 60 mais
j'attends vraiment
je sais pas pourquoi je stocke ses
entrées vont être un naufrage j'ai déjà
commencé
mais pourquoi ils ont commencé par vous
savez je sais pas moi mais aurait on
commence par scanner chez un grand
comédien
ouais regardez il arrive même pas monté
sur ça c'est sympa mais ça c'est la
règle et c'est vous dire et qui monte
dans un échafaudage et jean michel
lemaire c'est khaled c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aïcha en chef avec qui vient juste rien
eu mais tu vas travailler le personnage
c'est du roi semaine michel becquet me
mais ça sent la tristesse
ah là là mais 100 mg et vous serez en
ont dirigé pas en dire un personnage
gentil rodriguez oui mais non daly
semoun pas exactement
merci mais si tu n'es pas pour voir si
on est malade je suis bien là ça va
grieco savoura pour l'ensemble pour
l'instant on va on va passer une
chanteuse qui a explosé grâce au film la
vérité si je mens alors ça aussi c'est
une cata enfin vous préviens tout de
suite c'est une star avec la ja la bim
ares alabina c'est consiste à ramadi
[Applaudissements]
non
elle depuis qu'elle est arrivée sans
rigoler ça fait depuis qu'elle est
arrivée d'henri michaux qu'elle me dit
je danse très bien l'oriental c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
hello
merci très bien géraldine rester là ça
va pas bravo très belle prestation vous
êtes là elle est où est elle est là mais
vous êtes tous macha côté delphine à
côté de gens mis d'accord il ya combien
de monde on va passer un trio qui a
marqué l'histoire du rail
voici mes à deux trois sets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
est ce que vous avez à marquer l'hôtel
sursaut et comment ce gentil ça va plus
venir dans l'assaut
la marche ou pas on dirait le mec en
face à nac sinon ils vont te raconte
tout et en tout cas des trois la pizza
des programmes ce cas quelle heure mais
vous mes profs on trouve ses coûts cette
danse orientale on m'a dit
[Applaudissements]
sur la demande et lui vous l'avais
touché c'est le jean jacques du club
il est tout content d'arriver à
ouarzazate
alors on va dès lors il ya mounir qui
m'a dit qu'on allait donc souriante
holtz et l'arrivée sur la piste s'est
terminée par un gars 2001 j'avais mal
mais ça me va très bien je vous remercie
dieu bénisse et vous toujours magnifique
j'ai essayé un jeune arrive pas mais
j'essaye de dons un oriental est tous
avec les épaules un peu comme vous aimez
vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir un chanteur que j'adore et
là il est avec nous ce soir c'est le
petit prince du raï faudel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que j'ai des chiffres qui
tombent tous les quarts d'heure avec à
des gens qui nous regardent
alors ça ça ça c'est faudel ça ça c'est
pas de ma faute s'il est un peu moins de
succès en ce moment alors s'il a
beaucoup de succès fou d'elle et ça ça
ça c'est faudel ça ouais bah oui mais
pas pourquoi on sait que votre danseuse
non c'est vrai parce qu'elle était
derrière danse tous les deux pour le
kiff allez olla rhône et c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça commence à avancer que si vous nous
rejoignez chercher que francesca elle
n'a pas caché elle est amoureuse de
mathieu oui pour l'instant mathieu n'est
pas vraiment sur le délire mais j'ai
l'impression ont dit la semaine
prochaine avoue whalen jeu c'est dans
l'église s'y fixer une date et dans les
coulisses est fixe et non mais j'ai
l'impression que ça se sache se portent
très très très très bien tout ça